IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME VIN
SANITY!
NOW VIN DIESEL IS VIN-ZAYNLY
POPULAR ON FACEBOOK.
85 MILLION PEOPLE LIKE HIS
OFFICIAL PAGE, WHICH MEANS THAT
EVERY PHOTO HE PUTS UP GETS
RIDICULOUS LIKES.
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU TWO
PHOTOS FROM VIN'S FACEBOOK
PAGE AND FOR 250 POINTS, HAVE TO
TELL ME WHICH PHOTO GETS MORE
LIKES FROM HIS LEGION OF VIN
DISCIPLES. ALL RIGHT?
OK, FIRST ONE.
GIVING THE PEACE SIGN WITH A
BOTTLE-FED TIGER. OR, OR --
GIVING THE PEACE SIGN ON STILTS
IN A FIELD WITH COWS.
BARON.
>> I THINK THE ONE WITH THE
TIGER.
BECUASE OBVIOUSLY VIN DIESEL IS
THE BEAST MASTER.
>> ALL RIGHT, LET'S FIND OUT.
WHICH ONE.
YES, THE TIGER.
>> CHRIS
>> YES, BARON.
>> THAT ONE EASY BECAUSE IT
TAKES A WILD ANIMAL TO TAME A
WILD ANIMAL.
>> YES, OF COURSE IT DOES.
>> ALTHOUGH, SO THE OTHER ONE--
>> IT LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE
SQUEEZING FRESH BLOOD INTO THE
TIGER'S MOUTH.
>> FOR SURE. IT'S BARBEQUE AND
BLOOD.
>> VAMPIGER.
>> IT'S A VAMPIGER.
>> HOW PISSED IS THE TIGER.
ON HIS FACE BOOK PAGE HE HAS TWO
LIKES.
>> YEP, ON TIGER FACEBOOK.
NEXT ONE.
FAKING A PHONE CALL TO IMPRESS
HIS MAMMOTH DOG, OR STEELING A
TREE TO IMPRESS THIS SMALL
CHILD.
I JUST RIP THIS RIGHT OUT OF
THE GROUND.
[LAUGHING]
>> I STOLE IT FROM A TIGER.
ALICE.
>> THE ONE WITH THE TIGER.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: THERE'S --
>> THE DOG ONE, THE DOG TIGER
ONE.
>> YA, OKAY.
LET'S FIND OUT.
DOG TIGER.
>> DOG TIGER.
>> HE'S ON THE PHONE WITH
A TIGER.
>> NO, I'M NOT SEEING A MASTIF.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
NO BABY, I'M JUST BANGING YOU
TIGER.
LISTEN, I DON'T WANT TO START
RUMORS BUT VIN DIESEL DEFINITELY
[BEEP] TIGERS.
>> LAST ONE, GOING FACE-TO-FACE
WITH JASON STATHAM USING EVERY
TRICK TO LOOK TALLER -- LOOK AT
THE SHOES -- OR GOING
FACE-TO-FACE WITH HIMSELF.
YES DAN.
>> OH, COME ON. VIN ON VIN.
>> OKAY, LET'S FIND OUT.
OH, NO, JASON STATHAM.
>> IT'S TOO MUCH DIESEL FOR THE
PEOPLE.
>> WAS JASON STATHAM IN THE
MOVIES OR WAS THIS A PICTURE OF
THEM BEING IN A CAR ACCIDENT ON
FAIRFAX.
>> THAT WOULD BE AMAZING. OF
COURSE. OF COURSE.
>> YEAH.
>> OF COURSE, YEAH.
>> YOU WERE JUST PULLING OUT OF
THE GROVE AND I DIDN'T KNOW YOU
DIDN'T HAD THE SIGNAL ON.
OH, I DON'T KNOW, YOU STPID
[BLEEP], YOU WERE COMING OUT OF
THE GROVE.